that's cool yeah it does look punk rock
museum all right big boy toys it's a
celebration of innovation and opulence
and it's back in Las Vegas this weekend
JC is showing us all kinds of fun stuff
he's live at the convention center with
a preview of all the things going on
there how you doing buddy JC can you for
can you finally just tell everybody what
really happened on the track what
miles per hour Kendall did 128. 132 is
faster than 128. okay excited
all right all right guys this place is
amazing Big Boys Toys is back this is
Bijou he's the man behind everything
we've got a lot of stuff we want to get
to in the next couple minutes first off
visual so many great things that people
can see this weekend including these
combat motorcycles tell me more about
these these you have six bikes here with
which is worth more than a million
dollars
custom built right custom built and I've
been doing this for the last 12 years
I've never seen motorbikes like this
yeah these things are just Insanity
Insanity on two wheels gorgeous custom
Bikes let's keep on walking those so
people can come here this weekend they
can check out these bikes absolutely and
and then you go to see
you've got to see this the black flame
this thing is a helicopter almost like a
helicopter no no it's a vertical
takeover vehicle so almost like Star
Wars
literally like Star Wars science fiction
now how much does something to sell for
it's it's I'm told it's something Less
close to 200 000 when it's out there
okay but you you can just take off
wherever you are Big Boys Toys is
happening all week it starts tomorrow
Friday Saturday and Sunday see come here
look at these amazing things that they
have come around the corner here because
this is the little this scooter I call
it a scooter that I was riding this
thing can go up to 70 miles per hour
police actually use this to chase down
the bad guys on the highway this thing
is nuts it's so much fun as well and
this thing is the Crown Jewel behind us
what is this what is this thing right
here I'm lost I've been telling the mech
suit what is the mech suit why what is a
Mexican you tell me that that is a
Mexican it's like Iron Man
it's something you're controlling see
he's
operating it
and and this weekend if you can't see
all these things and this is something
you can register to actually win a
chance to operate that piece that
missionary it's moving it's moving look
it's starting to walk this is like
something out of Star Wars Star Wars
meets Iron Man right now is what I'm
saying
oh my gosh oh you guys Big Boys Toys
happens it starts tomorrow this is an
official sneak preview Friday Saturday
Sunday here at the Las Vegas Convention
Center buy your tickets and check out
the stuff yourself it's amazing Kendall
Rocky I'm gonna send it back to you guys
in the studio but I'm gonna try to ride
that thing please don't yes please go
for it buddy I say yes I mean I can
barely handle him on the 70 miles per
hour scooter okay that things look scary
too right it's crazy look if Bijou said
he was lost oh my gosh that's so much
fun all right speaking of toy